just Ben Affleck own
Aflac insurance
to Bear imagine this I really don't want
to imagine it took me a second and now
insurance come imagine you have a very
unusual kind of slightly unappealing
sounding name now imagine that somehow
there's a huge insurance company that
also has that name now imagine that
insurance company has a a bottomless
budget to buy television commercials and
now imagine that their
creative choice is to hire a duck to
shriek your last name and as loud and
obnoxious away as humanly possible for
the duration of the television
commercial and then imagine what it's
like when you're on an airplane and the
hammered lady behind us recognized and
thinks she's going to do her best
Gilbert Gottfried for six hours New York